In nineteen eighty. After the first couple had come to share the land.
We met some others who also were looking for a place to live and build a place. They have.
And we decided between ourselves. Ok. They're the right sort.
They're the sort of people would like to share the land with. Let's invite them. So we did. So they became the next.
The next layer of. That you feel and then there is people's. Members of family brothers.
And eventually the parents came. Said that it's a sort of set of extended families. In a way.
But basically it has to be. People being invited by the present. Members. To come and live here.
And not just a matter of a money. Transaction like buying a few. On the property. Legally.
We had to live beyond a little. As it were for about eight years. Which i must confess gave me.
Times when i was very concerned and worried. Not only the possibility.
The risk that was there always that something could turn nasty in the council. Come and try and. Boulders.
Some of the houses that had been built. But also the feeling that. I was take nick least still. The chief.
Shareholder in the company which owned the land. And all these people who had come on our invitation.
Virtually were unprotected by the law. And the s. It.
That they had put in the houses they had built and the trees that planted were technically not.
There is fortunately this. Never amounted to anything. I think. Other than a bit of a worry on my part. That something.
Unfortunate could happen that way. Because by about nineteen eighty six or seven i'm not quite sure which.
Council had at last. Agreed to accept the possibility of allowing multiple occupancies.
In this particular corner of the issue. Now the. Once they were in a position to accept. Multiple occupancies.
As a legal way of use. Land use. We were able to submit. Application for multiple occupancy. This.
Put them into a slight slightly awkward position because they were already. Say well.
Many many more houses built on that land than. Were legally allowed under the old scheme. But. They had enough.
Gentleness and sense. To sort of a point or a very. Isn't building inspector who gave us. Reasonable.
Attentions says that.
Allow those certain aspects of most of the had to have something done to them to bring them up to his satisfaction.
And ordinance. Seventy. We didn't really suffer too much. From that side of complying with the legal structure.
So legally. Each member of community has one share. Has one heard.
And has the right to dispose of his or her house and. General area. Liking. Garden.
Prague garden that has been established only.
To someone who is approved by one hundred percent of the rest of the community.
We have had one situation where this is already happened. It does.
It did because a problem for the for the people who wanted to move away. Because they couldn't sell their things.
Their house. On the open market. They couldn't ask. As much as they would have got on the connecticut.
And it took them. Much longer. Probably than it would have the say. I just left it on the open market. But.
This is something we all agreed to. Initially that. These are the conditions. So that. I mean that.
There are some disadvantages in that since this is not an investment. The place to live in that is very high priority.
Yes it's very important to us that we. We we've always tried to put. Relationship. Among community members. Absolutely.
At the top priority. Doesn't matter bet. Anything else really. If your relationship good. And of course.
The longer you can live. And share this. Live beside each other and share. The land or anything.
The longer you can do that and make a billy. The mole. Easy it becomes.
So that now i think there is a very strong bond. A bonding that is sort of. You know getting towards something like.
You get between brothers and sisters or family. I hesitate to use that word.
Family because it becomes rather a potentially. Nasty label in some communities. Doesn't it.
But it certainly seems to work. That. There's a good deal of support for each other if.
If somebody is sick or somebody. Well. When. When anyone has a baby. That the tradition. Has become that.
They get their a meal. An evening meal. Prepared and delivered for. Fortnight after the birth. And we take it.
We just take it intends to do that and i mean that. That's nothing but they just. There is lots of other support.
Sort of awareness of each other and awareness of shopping needs transport needs hills. It's it's it's a good one.
I actually wish it. Listen live it. Ideally you know. I must confess that. At first and i thought community i thought.
Working side by side in the gardens. You know producing things and working together. Projects. Be great. Now.
We come together. For social reasons. Party. This. Days. We come together to swim. In our big dam. In summer.
Which is a lovely. Escape place. We come together. Almost unfortunate occasions when we get a groundswell notice.
And also and have to show some signs of doing something to placate the. The rather than the rather absurd request.
To eradicate this. The days of potential danger to some people or. Some graziers any way. We come together is if.
There is a request to come together. But. We have a monthly meeting to discuss various business. Usually attended by.
That twenty percent. Maybe sometimes. Thirty or forty percent of the people but very rarely that it's.
Everybody comes to meetings. And yes i do think the did. Changed over the years. At first we did.
I think share an ideal or. A fantasy that you know we would be working side by side and.
We did have a community garden going for a while and. It just it seemed not to be the way.
We as people worked a bit as people moved into their own home.
Which was separate from each other they found it was more successful.
Useful to have their own gardens near their houses. Then they could choose what they wanted to plan.
They wouldn't have to go. Sort of three hundred yards away carrying the tools. Is it. It has just generally changed.
That's that side of his day much as we used to run a shop for ourselves. Come to think of it. We had. We.
We did weekly purchasing we had been full of. Oh gosh. So everybody. Chickpeas. We all get acquitted of course.
We had a great week grinding meal because we all made our own brit. Ernest. Lots of things that we've and that.
I think it was partly that. The payment system we had a book. We ended everything in.
But there was then really enough money in the. Kitty. When we came to do the next lot of purchasing.
Not because anybody had been dishonest or did. It's just that it wasn't convenient for them and. At the time.
Says that over a period of a couple of years of trying to run this thing for us. We decided that.
It just would be easier. At that time to let it go. What was just you know.
I think we probably have each come to our assessment of an energy level. And have that. It's more convenient.
To do things under our own steam.
Rather than to try to combine with each other the amount of energy needed to organize a shopping list. Among.
Twenty people each week. To to do the purchasing is to distribute the product. To get the pay back.
To get the money for the next weeks. All of that energy. Just seemed to be too much for any one person.
To take are so it has boiled down to each family. Seems to have its own transport system anyway.
He has to go to the shops. Sometime during a week or fortnight.
It just has boiled down to the fact that each individual family now does it. Does that side of things. Good still.
Mind you. If we go to a major crisis in the pickle supplies or a major shift in the whole economic system.
So that there is a lot less money to go around and lot less petrol to go around.
I wouldn't be surprised if we wouldn't be forced to get back into some sort of system like that again.
So i can say that it's due to personal. Laziness or just. Failure of that ideal.
It's just the way things have happened. You know so you can stay. And this was with them at that. I know men.
Very often used to think this is just another suburban plot. I think. Know that it's moved beyond that.
I think it's the community side of things the support of each member. For each other member.
Perhaps that support isn't called for more than very occasionally. But when i was sort of with a go.
If you need something. Or if you need a shoulder to cry on or if you need some information for fixing something.
And i think. I think one of the values that. In this community is that he who is enough. Right into the skilled sorry.
So yes. This certainly is a feeling that. We want to support each other when anything happens to any individual.
This does of course is. Support. If anybody's. Sick or hurt or.
If as occasionally happens the sort of relationship problems or break downs. There is not as not blame is just.
Support for each individual. Because of course we like. Each individual.
This is sounding like a sunday school something is becoming you know. Situation. So personally i don't think it does.
It may well be that some. Some individuals. Think that person ought to behave themselves. In which case it's.
It's their responsibility to say that. To that person and not say it to anybody else. That.
This is something that we've tried to follow all along. Is if. I have a grudge against somebody else in the community.
Or if i think they're doing something i don't like. I have to try to say to myself. Is this worth while.
Just accepting. Ok that's them. That's the way they like to do things or. Is it better for me to go to that person.
And because they know me i know them as a friend. Say. I don't like that or. Why you doing there.
Or you wake me up in the mornings when you do that. Now just to make. Each other aware.
If there is something that is irritating. And then it's up to us as individuals to work that out between us.
What we try to avoid and i think successfully use. Talking about that you would buy wonders. Talking about that.
To other people. So that when it starts going around. And round in circles. So i think that's one way that perhaps.
We've tried to keep each other. Aware of where we're possibly. Against another cell. In the community.
Because those guys. Yes. It has had this. Fairly stable population.
Although there have been people who have moved away for very good reasons.
There hasn't been any big blow ups or any sort of emotional strife that seems to cause people to move away.
They've moved away. For economic reasons or for health reasons one which you know. And yet is.
To be economically sustainable is. Is quite a mouthful isn't it it's quieter. And that she meant. I guess with.
Ideally we wanted that to be happening. It's taken much longer than i ever hoped they were thought it would.
But i think that it's. It's been happening over the last several years now that people have become more and more.
Pendant of any form of government support.
There is still a few people on the place who are pensioners or unmarried mothers or. You know. Single parents.
That with fear and but on the whole. Most of the. Health people and abuse ition have made jews. That they can work in.
That will bring in a viable income. So although it's taken longer than i'd hoped all. We all hoped it. It is happening.
And it's. I think. Another. Another sort of a fit of not having to pay rent. Of having a reasonably. Adequate.
Was a place to live it was. Each each family. Seems to built and home.
Gradually taking a long gun and a lot of this it.
Since none of them was you know a qualified builder to begin with but now they've each got a reasonably comfortable
and sound. Place to live in which is without a mortgage. And without. No overhead cost.
So that that in itself helps to make it possible to make a living out of either the kraftwerk or the music.
You know who's really. I wouldn't you know i mean. Yeah i would actually do it is all there are cliche.
Ok yeah that can i tell you bruce mcnichol and be a good one to talk to about that. You know him as a musician.